welcome to the dark forest checking your
pals were there for for us shameless
confession about our obsession will make
us laugh and smile so let's explore the
dark forest hello and welcome to the
dork forest you know the websites Jackie
Kashian calm dork forest calm the dark
forest calm it's another episode it's
movember I'm doing I'm doing like eight
episodes this month Patrick Brady fixed
the audio that's right because that's
one of the credits my GRIK burg just
sang that song he composed that that
song and sang it with his girlfriend
Sarah Cohen he will sing again at the
end of the program now other website
being done by Vilmos yeah he does Jackie
Kashian calm and he could do yours if
you want hired gun coding calm if you go
to that and check out his website making
skills knock yourselves out this month
is november november and december i ask
that you do not donate to the dark
forest donate there's 10 out of months
that you can donate to the dork forest
10 bucks a month gives me a hundred
bucks of a year from everybody that
would be great but in November you
should find a food bank in your local
area cuz what the heck couple of months
a year you could give them to ten bucks
a month maybe or whatever you have if
you google the words food bank and then
the name of your town the one will show
up doesn't matter where you are you
could be in nairobi and i bet you
there's a food bank and you could help
them up anyway so that's that if you do
want to get a t-shirt or a CD or dvd
that's available at Jackie dedication
calm in the store so my new CD and DVD
this will make an excellent Horcrux are
available there you can also go to all
things records all things comedy calm /
Jackie Kashian to download a five-dollar
version of the video instead of buying
the DVD you could just get it for five
buck download and all things comedy by
the way calm they're making a great
space for people to record
podcasts for comics to record their
podcasts I do it in my living room but
it's really it's going to be a really
nice space and I'll think comedy is
looking for a five dollar donation from
everybody and then that'll pay for it
that'll do all the equipment and
everything and it's the bill burr al
Madrigal Podcast Network and there's a
lot of great podcasts on there including
erin foley and and Eddie Pepitone and
Baron Vaughn and a thousand others that
I'm spacing out Tom papa then I'm
spacing at this time but they're very
good and so if you're always looking for
new podcasts go to all things comedy
calm and look it browse their pods the
other way you can help the show if you
want as we go into the holiday season
you can use the amazon banner on Jackie
Kashian calm there's a white banner sort
of the right hand side and it's just a
portal back into amazon and then you
ordered normal and then i get a kickback
I get a little taste of whatever from
amazon and we all order from them so if
you're going to order from them and
you're not using somebody elses portal
use my portal what the heck Jake
occasion calm other than that I think
that is it there's going to be a nice ad
in a second for Bob Calhoun's book and
this is a great episode but it comes out
November 21st happy thanksgiving if you
enjoy the Thanksgiving holiday if you're
have a war on Thanksgiving weird weird i
say but i'm going to be headlining in
los angeles at flappers burbank and that
is friday the 28th and 29th and then in
December I'm the first weekend to
December the fourth through the seventh
I'm with Brian Regan all over the coast
of california san luis obispo santa rosa
Temecula and Bakersfield and then the
following week I'm in michigan in ann
arbor and then I'm in Aspen Colorado
December twentieth so these things are
upcoming anyway let's get into the show
it's a good one it's a really good one
enjoy shattering conventions shattering
conventions shattering shattering hey I
sang it's Jackie Kashian shattering
conventions commerce cosplay and
conflict on the x
both floor by Bob Calhoun is this
month's sponsor it's a hilarious and
disturbing book friend of the show
conventions dork Bob Calhoun has been on
the show previous episode he goes to all
kinds of different conventions trade
shows and expose and writes about it in
shattering conventions but he doesn't
just go to comic-con and Star Trek
conventions he goes to a gun show a
livestock show a Republican convention a
conspiracy convention I remember being
slightly worried when he went to that
one and even a Bigfoot hunter con
there's all kinds of crazy and wrong in
this book and it's not always where you
expect to find it not only have I read
this book i endorsed it with a blurb on
the back cover and I recommend it to all
Rangers of the dark forest and spooky
reading girls within the sound of my
voice the book is shattering conventions
commerce cosplay and conflict on the
expo floor by Bob Calhoun it's available
in ebook and paperback from amazon.com
and other fine booksellers for more on
the book go to shattering conventions
com it's really good luck you should get
it hey it's Jackie Kashian welcome to
the dork forest sitting in my living
room hooray jimmy pardo welcome back to
my Jackie is good to be back at jimmy
pardo on the twitter and never not funny
hugely popular six months just found out
six months longer than the dark forest
you've been you've been in the business
ground floor like plastics uh you got in
the ground floor of a podcasting before
me march two thousand six oh that's it
that's it yes then mine September 2006
yeah i got in i heard you were thinking
about it i said she will not beat me to
the punch on podcasting how did you hear
about it cuz i heard about it at an open
mic about what about podcasting uh Matt
Belknap was doing a podcast called AST
radio before both of us yeah yeah at
Belknap ground where's Ricky Gervaise
was doing it before us yeah I don't give
a [ __ ] Oh Ricky Gervais swell that's
what I know that guy that's how I knew
what a podcast wasn't Ricky ok and then
Matt came to my house he was doing this
AST radio and it really what I don't
even know if it was called a podcast yet
but he could but he would like put it up
on a special thing calm ok interviewing
comedians ok
then part of me after he did mine he
walked he said he goes I think I have
more fun producing a show for you okay
so we then we tried to turn my talk show
at the UCB into a podcast right and then
we ended up just doing that like this we
ended up being at my house across the
dining room table for a year with Mike
Schmidt and then Mike left the show r
and uh and we've been going ever since
ever since this is a real nice card
table that's what we're working on here
this isn't this is a nice table this is
a real nice this folds up goes right
behind that door holds it up you put it
out of the way out of the way regular
social things happen in this little room
when I'm not recording the drive been in
this living room for social events
that's right we're gonna do it again
we're gonna do it again I don't know
when them but one day we're gonna have
another social event i'm in favor of it
so this will be available to the people
i like to call it dropped some people
make fun of me I don't know why it's not
an album but I mean that's what happens
is I drop it into the internet and the
internet puts it back I don't drop it oh
yeah I you uploaded oh yeah well I don't
know I'm gonna eat on the talent and
Groundhog Day did you did he just refer
to himself as the town that's a great
one of my favorite lines November 21st
which is weird cuz one one week later
the pard casteth on the day after
Thanksgiving park cast upon it goes rain
a noon to midnight over it you specific
time Pacific tat the Acme theater oh
good about the rain I'm very importantly
it streams live at never not funny calm
okay and it's a telethon to raise money
for Smile Train so if you can give money
it surgery only cost 250 dollars and
takes 45 minutes to change the child's
life right but donate a dollar donate
five dollars donate as much as you can
yeah and fix cleft palates all over the
world it's a great organization i'm
proud to be associated with them and we
have raised close to half a million
dollars for them that's about my stupid
little podcast that's si si helper Magoo
that's you no no nope no no doors ever
refer to me is that but I I will welcome
to the dork florist helper Magoo helper
Magoo I'm Chandi Magoo my sister bossy
Miguel yeah but i'll fill we can fill
keishon yeah location uh kind of a crier
Magoo Oh emo emo Magoo uh guess what he
at the coffee shop he's got somebody's
listening to the dork for us
hey everybody over at the coffee shop in
Minneapolis which is called cafetto tell
Phil that I call him emo Magoo if you
want ol doesn't listen but his friends
do yeah I'm a fan of that I like what I
have people like my cousins will go yeah
my best friend thinks you got the
greatest podcast what them even that
recommendation you don't listen nothing
nothing I've had more than more than
three members of my immediate family say
to me you know i don't really like
stand-up comedy hmm but you know i wish
you the best of luck at which point i
want to say you know I don't really like
money laundering haha whatever you do
for a living is awesome so Jimmy Pardo
let's get into this the band Chicago you
said you could dork out about the band
Chicago well I i mean i am a from
Chicago yeah of course they are well you
ain't could have been from Milwaukee I
don't know wasn't don't know no they're
from Chicago they were Scargill and they
are they white just what god I don't
know anything about of questions these
are a lot of questions yeah they well
they started in the late 60s there was
the they were called the Chicago Transit
Authority really and then the i believe
the mayor threatened to sue them if they
didn't change their name daily was that
Mayor Daley in the late sixteen that
would have been that would have been
there were some graph Richard J daily
yeah that sounds right dick daily and he
so then they changed their name to and
I'm this is I remember when do it this
was like an eight I think it's in the
first album in the liner notes so that
no them simply as Chicago and I always
whenever I read that I think it's in the
first the liner notes of the gatefold of
CTA which is name of the first album
okay uh which I want to say came out in
67 said would you have down there i have
i have Chicago Transit Authority
nineteen sixteen 69 huh yeah and then
chicago to 1970 yeah yeah boy I always
thought it would sleep maybe they got
together at 67 and then in the album
came out in 69 I think said yep you
gotta get a catalog before you go you
gotta play around right right are you
doing covers until then they were doing
covers at barnabys on state it was
really it was a state street a place
called Barnaby's and Chicago is how that
line of calls see something well it was
a
well I would have been one well I may
not appreciate it no you my Twitter loud
what have been really loud a lot of
trumpets um and they had they were
called the the big thing is what they
were called then okay and then they
changed her name to CTA okay um and then
chicago just straight as simply chicago
yeah okay yeah and then um and who's in
who's in the band how many our then then
well then you had the three horns you
had jimmy panko on trombone okay uh
let's run away run kilobases really yeah
and that's what he said I've met him a
couple times oh that's and he has been
nothing nothing but a nice man uh
recognized my name from television
thought I was a vo guy okay and then he
finally figured out that i'm a comedian
I don't know if you really figured it
out but I he's always kind of nice and
he always listened to we're living the
dream we're limit the dream we're still
are you putting put on the plate yeah
we're doing it that's it we're doing
we're doing our dream he's you know what
that is the best attitude ever it is any
goes I'm still too good looking at 70
years old I'm still doing this I'm still
playing a trombone trombone man still
looks oh he's always been he was the
sexy one in the band Oh was he uh he
would wear a leather vest on stage back
in the 70s mhm with nothing no shirt no
shirt oh that is a lot and look and and
even if they ring straight white man
here we go yeah course of course that's
what you're wearing you look great with
a 70s beard and the hair but here i
always say i would say oh I go Jimmy
where do you I go do you live in
Nashville with the other well wherever
your guild masks and then he nurses the
Kardashian gated thing yes yeah of
course it's in the money area right
right yeah yeah cuz hopefully still
getting my royalties he wrote and I
don't know how a linear you want to go
with this how timeline but he wrote make
me smile hero color my world he wrote
just you and me so he is making Bank a
zillion dollars right right that's just
who keeps coming so he's on trombone
this is back again the original CTA ok
Jimmy panko on trombone Lee locking in
on trumpet okay Walter para zader on
woodwinds ok Robert Lamm and keyboard
and vocal mm-hmm uh Peter Cetera on bass
and vocal he's the only one of
ever heard of Terry Kath uh guitar and
vocal okay and danny seraphine okay on
drums okay do you want me to then bore
you six people at seven seven PG
original seven so they go they go to do
a gig if they get a hundred dollars
everybody gets 99 bucks right but
through another dream they're living the
tourney food on the plate let me put him
in the plane maybe they got free food I
would imagine Barnaby's gave him
something rewriting a sandwich or
something meaning of it all but uh yet
so then so there that they're the core
they're the clear of the core and then
in in the in the mound 7677 my team in
75 a guy named a law dehradun lavera
joined discussion percussion brazilian
gentlemen Oh more more yeah more a you
know can't dare deal lavera mm-hmm and
then uh in nineteen seventy eight um in
january i believe it is if 1978 Terry
Kath took his life accidentally exhaling
yeah OD no he was showing uh I can't
pull the name right now the banter Don
Donnie something okay i think was dining
something he was showing a ban tech a
gun and it was loaded and it shot
himself in the head Wow um on thurs of
course conspiracy sure there wasn't
right cuz that's that guy other
conspiracies or something but he was not
happy he was depressed one could believe
it but I'm thinking or anyone collects
guns remember Freddie Prinze yeah 70s
sure yeah that was a guy had collected
some guns and wasn't things weren't
going well looking good looking good oh
sure so Terry passes away uh they
replace him with a guy named Donnie
Dacus who went by the nickname of hot
licks Donnie hot like Sudeikis get
that's guitar uh on guitar and he was
also before that he was with Stephen
Stills and he was also in the movie hair
oh is it not as Don Dacus uh it's one of
the as sort of an ensemble a guy uh when
he asked yeah one of the stars if you
know was treat Williams right uh beverly
d'angelo and Don Dacus okay three big
stars okay uh then Don joined Chicago he
adani
he was there for hot streets and 13 okay
then they got rid of him mm-hmm a guy by
the name of Chris pinnock joined down
guitar yeah he was there until cetera
left in 85 I when I Peter left an 85 a
guy named Jason chef replaced Peter and
a guy named Wayne Bailey replaced Chris
pinnock Wow then Duane Bailey was there
i want to say till 92 I'm sorry 1990
danny seraphine was fired oh wait a
minute go back go back in nineteen
eighty-two built champlin joined on
guitar vocal and keyboard okay then in
nineteen ninety Danny serve him was
fired from drums again in tris Imboden
okay joined on drums and then she is
employed more beautiful I play for them
for about a month adapt I was on timpani
oh lawd aire de Oliveira left in 82 he
left at 18 he took a stick as a Turkish
conga and at the end that ratchet took
that back yeah and uh and the head back
to go said other those who took those
away back to Brazil um Tristan boat and
join on drums in 1992 Duane Bailey was
fired and replaced by Keith Holland and
that's been the band ever since they now
have a guy a wall fredo raised on
percussion okay Jason chef again replace
peter cetera mm-hmm other than that we
have no more original four original guys
Rehan that's huge actually from 1969
that's that that's that's an amazing
kind of thing cuz they I mean aren't
there bands that there's one guy left
well some would say that's Chicago too
though that oh yeah I'm the league
because there were seven right to go and
see them and there's only four and
sometimes because these are guys are
getting up there in age sometimes you
can go see them and it'll be just two of
the four two of the four right one of
the four like sometimes there's only one
horn player to the other guys aren't
there regulus always there Robert lambs
always there yeah now is he one of the
vocal guys he is and he wrote beginnings
as imitating what time it is 25 or 6 to
4 Saturday park mm-hmm I a lot of its i
was listening last night to one of the
one of the greatest hits i think from 75
yes go go 9 Chicago 9 that's what I was
listening to that when I was like let's
get into it see if I'd know any of these
songs you know
normal yeah I know almost every single
song is yeah and I you know I'm not a
big like if somebody says what album do
I get in on what L them if I don't know
anything about Chicago what album would
I ever get in on ya I never like to
suggest you get the greatest hits but
Chicago 9 is a great way to wet your
whistle right to then see if you want to
journey further into Wang earlier L
because it's it's it's a it's a lot of
different kinds of albums but it there
is a definite through line that thing
and this was the time I believe whenever
we'd love talking about music I don't
know a great deal about it but I like
when we pick a band mm-hmm because then
I can really or there was a great
episode about sky had brandy Posey on
she I got to learn about ska Wow and you
talked for more than 15 seconds yeah
well she's loved she's a lover of the
sky ghetto is you she went into it she
got into it and she held for I don't
want that you don't want it that's if
you're allergic to nuts by the way
there's nuts and these cashews oh no I
know what you've been eating him for
about 12 minutes oh yeah so you know
what I I wanted the cashew and then I
realized nobody wants to hear me no joke
one guy really doesn't one guy emails me
he's like why why why is that happening
I'm like well don't worry about it it's
free and we're human beings and maybe we
don't want to pass out there has to be
some eating sometimes but yes horns I
love a band that has a band yeah I kind
of I mean I don't I myself do not enjoy
jazz you don't like Miles Davis I saw
Miles Davis live once and it was a whole
but that's all it well that's a great I
think that's one of those were you good
like you just said that's all it was you
check it off and you can tell people you
know so Miles Davis I saw Miles Davis
once it was neat it's like I saw Bob
Dylan once I've actually seen him or
other ones right first time I saw him
was not until maybe five years ago okay
and I remember going well I could check
that off right I can now say I saw Bob
Dylan it wasn't good it wasn't
entertaining but but I saw the legend
right great and I was I think Dana Gould
tells that story about seeing Sinatra
and he saw Sinatra and he couldn't Frank
Sinatra was genuinely old and couldn't
remember the lyrics to his own songs so
you can do in that situation is tick it
off right but with with with uh what's
his name uh Bob Dylan um I don't
understand what he's saying ever so I
love it when other people cover by Billy
because I like the songs but i like to
hear the works I like like if you buy
the two if you buy the essential Bob
Dylan yeah um where you know there's
some production value and stuff and you
can't understand what he's saying uh
somebody cleaned it out there's not a
clunker on there oh yeah it's really
really great right and and I you know I
am not to say anything my brother Phil
that's my brother Phil yeah big fan of
Leonard Cohen big fan of Bob Dylan those
are his tues Wow and so that's a
different it's a different guy than you
yes and you that you're you're a Chicago
guy I like Bob Dylan right Leonard Cohen
not at all not not as much I like
Leonard Cohen you kind of um it'sit's
gravely but again I like it when other
people cover it because then I can
understand what's being said yeah uh
what was his big hit um everybody news
remember everybody knows concrete blonde
did it in pump up the volume at the the
river phoenix film that was not
Christians Christian Slater rather was
on mca records right it was I just
watched it about three weeks ago I was I
decided to put in some crap I was like
I'm watching some crap tastic two weeks
notice music and lyrics pump up the
volume Groundhog Day uh I'm gonna say
pump up the volume didn't hold up at all
it does it does hold really weirdly
enough holds up pirate radio pirate
radio in a basement in a basement and
then driving around in a jeep with like
a ham radio broadcasting worked like a
charm right and PG weirdly enough back
in those days meant uh free boobs oh is
that true yeah that's weird right so
there's some so gentlemen ladies
everybody zoozoos into free boobs that's
listening out there Rangers get out
there rent pub of the volume might be
available streaming are we only that 89
or 90 what your did that movie come out
I think 89 90 what happens sometimes in
the dork forest is that the phone rings
and then I gotta go hang up on somebody
so tell a story about either a movie
that you love or a Chicago um well I
Sawchuk hago the very first time I saw
Chicago is 1982 ah no abort abort abort
1981 I saw that my friend Gary
I gary is a ended up moving to Nashville
and was amusing a touring musician and
wrote some songs and and had some hits
yeah and he was on tour with some some
famous artist died playing keyboards and
a backup vocalist write a really
talented guy who I went to high school
with and he took me to my I went with
him to see my first Chicago show and we
sat in the front row where'd you go
where'd [ __ ] I'll go fest it was an
outdoor toggle fest used to be a once a
year kind of like my wife s yeah same
okay yeah yeah okay um so was an outside
venue yes and was it just them well were
you open for them Lee written our oh
Jesus jazz guitar ilsley written our
yeah who I then got on board with and
then I've just gone away from but at the
time I you know okay because I don't you
know other before that I'd seen kiss you
know and right and so like to see
another artist live and celi written our
it was kind of like well now a big early
written our fan ya know and there's some
nostalgia there listening to that album
that was out in 81 right um and we went
to the afternoon with to the matinee
show cuz there was two shows because it
was a Chicago fest right and we got
there early because that's what Gary and
his friends wanted to do and we SAT uh
like I say the front row front row and I
knew Chicago because my dad is a huge
Chicago fan okay you not so much anymore
but at the time he was like this is a
great band yeah and he would play them
all the time in the you know in the car
or you probably had eight tracks he
would play surely the vinyl could chunk
um and so I knew the hits mm-hmm this
the show that i saw in 81 was one of
maybe three shows chicago did the entire
year okay and it's kind of it's a set
list that if I saw that setlist today I
would go that's the best set list in the
world yeah at the time I was thinking I
don't want any songs oh hey brother play
a couple of hits area because it was
like this really weird uh kind of
self-indulgence set yeah um a very
fan-friendly set casual fan not so much
yeah um is it was deep cut deep cuts the
got a song called mother
uh now I song called doing business that
wasn't released on an album until the
2000s when it was a bonus track oh
really yeah uh maybe the 90s was on a
box set okay but um but a deficit like
10 years 12 years after it had been
mowed 20 minimum the see if I saw maybe
one performed it a thousand times and
nothing doing business doin business all
right I've been evolved oh and uh here's
the here's video Peter Cetera uh like
like when they did do a hit like they
did Robert Langley saturday in the park
which they may have opened with okay
because it was a saturday in the park
alright i think was august first of 1981
okay and um they said uh that's Bobby
lamb that's Bobby lamb and I then spent
because my OCD head couldn't get
comfortable yep is it Bob Elam is it
Bobby lamb right what so we didn't know
what his name was names you sat in the
front row and that's the committee
meeting that you were holding in my hunt
is that and then so then they finally
they do another couple songs and then
Peter Cetera says will be introduced
everybody let's introduce the band on
drums that's dandy yeah you know who
everybody is look like you say that
pants name one more time one more time
yeah robert e lei yeah it is that his
name is a day it took me until i got
home and looked at the album what is it
it's robert lamm it is Robert Robert
ba-bam lamb Bobby and he wins Bobby in
the 80s for any and he hates it now Oh
does he yeah in fact I saw him recently
at the saban here in LA and some guy
Robert was up there talking and some
guys said I love you Bobby it goes i
love you too sir but i have been Bobby
for 20 years but with Magnum like
serious way like like I'm not just like
i am not a bartender don't call me Bobby
yeah yeah but he went by bobby was on
the it was in the albums right you burn
avoca Bobby lamb yeah uh but it was a
time of his life that I guess he chooses
to forget because of weird it's weird
that he kept the same job uh cuz it's
gonna be hard to forget that and be like
if I wanted to
start pronouncing my name kashien
because that's Mike a lot of my siblings
have done it now they were F because of
the Kardashians no no kids because the
archbishop of the the East Coast
Archbishop told my sister that it was
actually pronounced cash in or khushiyan
or whatever the [ __ ] it is acidification
instead occasion which is what my father
is always pronounced and and so three of
my siblings out of the six of us are
currently Reaper noun Singh their name
something weird and I'm like do whatever
you want thumbs down thumbs down thumbs
down the Bible on you three uh but Baba
but I get Bobby I you know I was Jim for
a while and yep uh you know and you know
so I get that you go through the phases
and you want you know a guy that you
want to walk the dinosaur you want to be
good right you're like a Tommy Tom yeah
PJ I think it was a drug-addled part of
his life then I kind of watched a person
wants to mature his way out yet so he's
like well no I'm past that it's also 79
anyways I mean there were there 70 years
old not this band are they really do
work she's perfect sense it makes I mean
1969 they were probably 20 yeah well by
Jesus leaves my dad was born in 43 and I
and most of these guys are the war then
right yeah of course you talk to this
country he fought for this case of
nature is 330 yeah he's they said about
they uh I used to do that joke about me
going to Vietnam my parents enemy to
Vietnam yeah I was three but I went did
you it's you know it's weird as I used
to cuz I have a buddy who was in ho chi
minh city in 1975 when the when the when
the regime fell because his dad was in
the diplomatic corps and i said we
Rihanna Ho Chi Minh Trail and your bike
fell over cuz that's right because he
would have been 70 yeah yeah yeahs or
something or 10 and so yeah yeah those
are great stories oh sure our God that
stuff warm good stuff war they so wait
what's right so they were born right
around the same time as my dad most of
the originals okay Robin 43 44 okay yeah
so their 7th or 70 there's 70 years
older mom and they're still planned
they're still playing out yes you know
mix for you know as much as they can but
but I ok so I i digressed i weeded this
off this whole the idea of the horns
like cuz I like big band okay big band
music and I like uh rock and I think
Chicago is a nice mix of the two of them
yes of course they're the rock and roll
with horns that's how they describe
themselves is that and I know I mean
that's how they describe themselves now
and and and in you know in the 60s and
70s in the 80s of course they went
through the phased everybody did where
everybody wanted to be you know I have a
diane warren hit and you know it's that
what do I power ballad oh ok you know so
you know they had hard to say I'm sorry
in 82 oh you're the inspiration I think
I tried to roller skate backwards to
both of those I I would imagine that was
writing that wheel right in that time
frame would have been the one uh you
know that what people called it you know
the downfall of Chicago which you know
those albums if you're not a power
ballad guy you know there's other great
songs on chicago 16 17 18 and 19 okay um
but but but that was the that was the
stuff that people were putting was the
norm I mean it was that was what
everybody was doing it was you know
every artist was doing that now some
could say well stay true to who you are
don't try to have a hit right the [ __ ]
does want a hits per my language what do
I knew people wanna hit you want to hit
ya and this is a band Chicago that you
know they have one time I think they had
four albums in the top ten Wow and like
they like everything was Chicago so
there were only other six other albums
right so I think Chicago five six seven
eight ten like they all went to number
one okay then they went then they
completely fell off the you know they
were nothing right and then they came
back in 82 with her to say I'm sorry and
it's like well this is it's a different
time different music we're gonna make it
right right and so we're gonna do this
yeah I think the first time I heard of
Chicago was on Casey Kasem yeah because
they were hits and he would count down
the top 40 sure and it was always it was
he would talk over the beginning of the
song it's my least favorite thing is to
talk over the beginning or the end of
the song where I was like well wait the
songs begun that's still part of the
song guys I'd like to hear the beginning
of the song I won't even yeah and it was
but um but I do i do like them it's it's
there's all of that stuff where are
there other bands that
I mean they were they were not unique in
in that well there was a blood sweat and
tears okay let's wait until I Chicago
action what's written peers hey uh who
were produced by the same guy Jimmy
Guercio James Guercio okay uh and then
you know uh there's one more from that
time that I can't pull right I be well
I'd zoo March some could argue the Ides
of March had some horns at him they'll
get long vehicle okay I'm a vehicle baby
I'll take you anywhere you want to go
Rick well cuz last night know when I was
listening to that the the greatest hits
there was a flute I don't know who is
playing a flute that's walked Paris
later on wood ones okay oh he's did the
whole all the woodland yeah saxophone
well oboe clarinet flute I didn't
remember that there was any flute I mean
I called her my world okay cuz i was
thinkin it was it was all jethro tull
for flute uh-huh that's all I was like
it had to be and it was it wasn't you
know cuz I think of Jethro Tull is more
of like acid rock I don't even know if
that's a its prized prog rock prog rock
yeah is Chicago considered progress no
they're called probably jazz fusion
probably okay uh you know that's the
weird thing I think that's part of the
problem that they had is that you didn't
know how to describe them because
somebody might have called a progress I
maybe wasn't sure I mean it's not as
moody as for although when they first
started know they did you know Robert
Lamm wrote you know uh dialogue or you
know State of the Union off Chicago five
and or even it's tough on Chicago three
you know again mother which is about
Mother Earth okay and uh flight 6056
what clues it okay but all like Vietnam
War uh you know era they had a song
called a song for Richard and his
friends basically tell Richard Nixon to
get out of here oh really I'm sick of
your [ __ ] okay uh you to a nice beat
with uh well some would argue that may
not be a nice beat add a song for
Richard in his friends okay I think it's
a pretty you got to be a big fan to dig
that okay but they you know they were
very uh like a story they're telling is
that sometimes it's like some of the
lyrics i was listening to they were kind
of sad well wait depends what song right
cuz they but there was there was a lot
they do a lot of love song well they did
even bet then see that's what's funny
you say that Jackie then you're funny
you're saying that Jackie boy point of
order dork oh please sweet Jesus
it uh everybody blames cetera and you
know if you leave me now in 1976 for
well that's where they sold out that's
where they became a [ __ ] man it's like
well just you and me is a love song you
know a color my world off chicago to is
a love song right now yes it has some
unique time changes changes in okay and
you know a structure and like there's a
great soprano saxophone solo in the
middle of just you and me okay which may
not have happened in the 80s but i would
have been a horrible synthesizer right
um but um that's kind of who they were
they were a mixture of this rock and
roll with horns and then they do a
ballad yeah and back to back and it was
a true but nobody thought it was weird I
give him cepillin what do going to
California we're after Black Dog you
don't ya like two different it's the
same band they saw the same vibe same
with wings I mean wings had like yeah
but some could argue that Paul McCartney
is just a sappy jackass and if the rock
and roll songs are the you or that or
older they're the rarity the exception
oh I'm not that guy what does I'm would
it's okay yeah it's but but I thought
that like cuz i only have I only have
hits and history the wings china which
is it is all you need cuz it's a lie
it's gotta be 50 so dogs got everything
right so some of them are some of them
are really sappy and some of them are
are well a jet yeah band on the run bad
another run is in my top five favorite
songs of all time and I'm to be three
different songs I said yeah yeah yeah
isn't it doesn't it hurt it just moves
going on in the den of it then yet and
on right it seriously it goes from its
long yeah it changes major time code
time code I can't be it that's not what
I'm the time to 4 4 to 6 8 or what is
that called because that's what I'm sure
that's the same thing I'm trying to
think of yeah yeah it's and I was happy
when you say time changed I just went
along with it yeah it's not what I meant
but I close it off with it like as long
as I can come to somebody named I'm sure
Oh someone Ross Whitman you out there
you know yelling at the ipod this nerd
that's on here to talk about music I
can't think of like the most I can't
remember the name of it man I'm out a
musician that's it let's do you play an
instrument no did you ever play this
I took guitar lessons okay okay then uh
I'm that I admit that I'm that [ __ ]
that thinks Oh at the party I can't no
no no oh no that guy's another vessel
I'm the guy who if I'm not playing after
three lessons yeah oh I'm not God the
same for me right like I literally think
i should get those tapes from esteban
right an infomercial or not if I guitar
in six hours and then all of a sudden
you're and I really Jimmy look I'm not
the sort of hot luxardo tour false
Jackie yeah I was in a band in high
school called rainbow bridge and I want
it to be true I would jokingly say I i
I'm an introduce the band to say and I'm
Jimmy hot licks Pardo wow that feels
true no its pulse of course it's true of
course it's true true oh my god yeah so
yeah there's a lot of sense all like
color yet like would you say color my
world just you and me but those are
really the oh no I wishing you were here
your son is on the greatest hits okay um
but for the mantra that first that first
greatest hits I mean you know beginnings
is on there which is in my top five
favorite songs of all time okay uh yeah
it's only the beginning that one okay uh
25 or 6 to 4 is on there that's a rock
song with horns yep let's see just you
and me down there wishing you were here
call on me is on there okay hold on me
cuz okay so not blondie nope yeah that's
a different does what I mean how many am
i up to what did i do it let me see if I
can lay it name that songs on the
greatest hits okay beginnings 25 or 6 to
4 color my world just you and me make me
smile okay wishing you were here call on
me to ever say calling me I don't think
I don't know what I've done now right
now now it's a blur that said what are
these other 30 saturday the park okay Oh
does it mean know what time it is okay I
have a surgeon so long I've been
searching so long minami yellow I like
all that and I like I cuz for me in high
school it isn't right I was big Billy
Joel fan big Billy Joel fit why is that
not right because the mocking over the
last thirty seven thousand years
that I have received you know what's
interesting Jackie about that is I am
very outspoken and and I and I've come
around I want to be very clear okay I am
outspoken on my hatred of Billy Joel oh
you're on record I am i doing on every
record possible on how he will punch him
in his scraggly bearded face and uh and
that he's horrible but Christie Brinkley
cleaned him up bought her a turtleneck
yeah they were the worst it was the
worst year but all that said I I've come
full circle so no for a circle I mean I
still hate him ah I've I've got a
complete 180 right there right yeah 360
s full circle yeah I where is like I
admit that I'm wrong it turns out it's
one of those things where I just don't
like the album I don't like an innocent
man i don't like that album oh and i
don't like some river of sighs okay
other than that it turns out i like a
lot of Billy Joel yeah those those two
albums are just I mean they're they're
just okay I mean literally an innocent
man is him he is a monkey throwing
things at a wall right it's grim its
grad some of them have a good beat but
they're gross that's hunger yeah and
that's the longest Oh number one that's
my number one like I want to murder him
right well it's cuz it's this homage to
his own childhood and you're like stop
stopping yourself nobody wants to watch
this and but everybody bids here's a
wheeling everybody wanted to watch it
everybody had album was humongous of MTV
though I think that MTV made him some
sort of weirdo star because Christie
Brinkley and I remember in college
reading an unauthorized biography at
Billy Joel know somebody behind the
scenes right right where it was just
about the love story but it was older
because he had broken up with Christie
Brinkley and was then going out with a
woman who was 12 years younger than
christie brinkley that looked exactly
like christian which made you want to
bury him headfirst and paint his feet
with honey and then call aunts yes it
was so furious but i love cold spring
harbor it was one of his first uh his
first album it was it was at first one
is it that is his first one but he had a
band before that called I forget the
name but and then
but cold spring harbor is one of my
favorite albums of his and then i love i
really enjoy street life serenader a
great deal and nylon curtain I've been
listening nylon curtain actually for the
last six months almost I'm non-stop
really is that the one with the second
it's got Saigon and downtown and Nick or
what it would say the pressure pressure
yes I'm yeah that's on there that's not
one of my favorites but but I do it but
it has a Scandinavian skies and it's got
Laura it's got its it's interesting and
he's I love his saxophone playing he's
got that guy Anthony or Tony or would it
I don't know the name of the day some
guy from Jersey also plays a musical
instrument he's a he's a guy maybe the
Long Island he might have met him from
so yeah uh you and my big problems with
Billy Joel and it's not even his fault
what it's his alcoholism no that's none
of your life enjoy yourself it and you
know this is a comic going to one
nighters like we did in the late 80s
Early 90s mm-hmm and they would do the
comedy show and then the dance forward
open and then eventually usually but
most one nighters were in a like a
college town okay you know uh at least
back then but that's a pretty nice one
nighter I was doing some best western
for wall in it somewhere in the middle
of but there's a college nearby right
there might a bit of college near but
inevitably and I'm and by the way I wish
stay there until they told me to leave
because I was a drunk okay inevitably
piano man would come on oh yeah and
every college frat idiot they would join
arms and this happened nationwide right
as they would say Lord okay no man right
it's like you're 20 you can't relate to
this [ __ ] song at all and it wouldnt
finally more in common with this and I'm
24 I'm work because I'm an entertainer
who is sadly just performed here right
and everybody's going you were great why
are you here like we literally lived
that song right and it would infuriate
me to watch these these college kids who
are they're getting drunk and then
they're gonna go do homework and go to
class yeah thinking they can relate to
this 40-year old guy hash it out the key
right just had his entire life stolen
from him which is why he's working at at
LAX piano bright yeah you can't relate
to that chair I so stop it right so I
would I
again I took all that out reading Billy
Joel Oh fair enough fair enough cuz they
were all so I took it out on Kerouac cuz
i was like cuz they're also reading
Kerouac and hunter s thompson force them
Bukowski and you're like yeah none of
those people you are absolutely i'm very
sorry yeah it's all working out you and
your suburban life and you don't even
have any student loans I'm very I can't
even sympathize you know it's funny you
say that you bring that up it's uh you
know I listen to Sirius XM okay and raw
dog 99 is one of the channels I listened
to and I oh yeah and I because they do
the stand up yeah sending a comedy so I
would know I will bounce around from
down the channels and Bill Hicks who you
know we I loved we add ya pioneer
pioneer great phenomenal mm-hmm and i
know im gonna get a lot of hipsters
pissed off at me for saying this this
will be considered if i can go up with
phil hendrie blasphemy he i would say at
that time in his life eight out of ten
jokes would be well i read a book right
like it was a lot of you know bah blah
blah oh you guys are making movies out
there I'm in New York you know what
we're doing here reading yes oh look at
him he's a REIT like Jesus cry we get it
bill you're smart you're better than
everybody or the smarty Magoo yeah
here's the thing is uh what I I never I
never listened to stand up comedy Oh as
a child we'd weird Zig Ziglar a lot of
sell the sizzle not the steak and so
there was no stand-up comedy until i
started doing stand-up comedy and I
didn't even know who Lenny Bruce was how
did you got me ask you a question sure
and this is not about the band Chicago
and imed that were this far off exactly
i waited and now you how does one get
into stand-up comedy if they're not into
stand-up comedy uh one accidentally goes
to a stand-up comedy club and realizes
that you can drink there for free and i
heckled I that was my first I was the
the biggest nightmare right I was a
woman heckler drunk woman heckler Sam
Kinison was the first comic i ever saw
alive and i heckled him yeah oh and then
that girl Sam enjoyed women in the
audience yeah he loved women in the
audience and he's having the shittiest
set of his life by the way was is that
it was Bill Kinnison owned the club
Madison Wisconsin okay 1984 my
teen 85 90 the right way Sam was right
before he blew up yeah yeah yeah he was
about to do Letterman and he was a
coked-up and drunk at the same time cuz
that's what you want to be you want to
sort of find the right even it out and I
was in the front row of this dirtbag it
was a it was a the state street
infirmary on State Street in Madison
owned by Gus the guy who owns the the
club in Madison not really he owned that
building Wow and State Street infirmary
pool hall coke front underneath it
Comedy Cellar owned by Bill Kinnison and
the only people you get to come were cuz
remember this is supposedly the golden
an era this is the boom right he would
Bill Kinnison would pay 250 dollars plus
airfare and you stayed in a shitty
apartment for a week of stand-up comedy
so I went to uh to a show for some
reason I'm 18 19 years old yeah we go to
the comedy club we're sitting there I
literally was had to be the first time I
was out in public uh I am I had been
told that every time somebody brings you
a drink you tipped them a dollar so i
don't--there's not that is not pretty
but it's not crazy but it's not at a
comedy club you run at Everton pays him
uh so that I would every time she would
bring me a drink I'd uh I'd give her a
dollar she was back every two of course
I was like so I was hammered beyond
redemption kinnison's having a hard set
cuz he's a chip faced and so there's a
pause and I blurt something out that you
cannot understand I believe he said I am
from Peoria and then waited too long and
I said so I'm sorry I know making me the
worst human being on the planet by the
way but not only are you a drunk female
heckler mm-hmm you said like just
generic what a while yeah guy that like
every time someone heckles me by the way
you hear that I have to take a moment
and go oh this is payback yeah hey back
asshat I'm sorry yeah and that's the
worst like that that's the zero response
there's no response that's the
equivalent to in my opinion next and
then remember we want
of uh not all right right which there's
no come back to that because they're
like literally negating everything you
just said yeah which by the way of
course it's not that's comedy right
there's gonna be at wisteria twists
turns out if you were to wait two
[ __ ] seconds there might have been a
punchline I enjoyed yes that was those
are the ones that that always drove me
nuts I'm sorry and i have a very
specific time i remember in my head I'm
an audience member saying that I want to
throttle him right next and then not
those were the three and then all the
one time one guy this happened one time
in my life and I then was like well I
gotta have something prepared I so guy
yelled out nice forehead and I was like
I didn't know what to say back to it so
then of course I later I was like well
that were happens again I'm gonna you
know it's like I got to assume you're
describing the VCR at your house sir
like like just this convoluted thing and
then that happened in nineteen like 90
right nobody's ever yelled out nice for
hit again again right well that's why
they would but it's the best when you
plan for the thing that's never gonna
happen again is [ __ ] hilarious pardon
me well the one thing I did have to do
is uh I would always get stand up
because I'm not the tallest guy right
and so dumb you know a guy who feels a
little emasculated cuz this girl friends
laughing at me or his wife is laughing
and I go she can't she doesn't find me
funny and she finds this good funny
right that's always empty yells yeah
well why don't you stand up ah and then
so I then after maybe three or four
times of that happening I would I used
to open my show by literally within two
sentences mentioning my height in a
subtle way yeah so that when that
happened I would go right we cover that
in the first second I was up here Sarang
clay then that guy's stupid audience on
my side yeah um but yeah the preemptive
it's a preemptive strike where we're
comedy is a lot like Iraq oh sure she
had her the enemy know the enemy until
you have them on your side the one of
the worst when I first started doing
stand-up it was because I would
occasionally get fat comments and it
wasn't and there was nothing to be done
there's a the worst time hilariously in
retrospect very funny but an entire
group of frat guys chanting lose weight
at me which is brutal brutal
but you're just like all you can do is
go uh just I i believe at this entire it
was a debacle i started making fun of
their girlfriends cuz I didn't know what
else to do right and which the
girlfriend started whipping popcorn bags
at me and uh was a bad wasn't the great
yours was the great show so what I just
did is I looked at my watch and I said
another seven minutes they have to pay
me the $75 this was in the first year of
doing standing army and but the thing is
is that was saved because some guy in
the front row offered me a joint and he
goes it'll be fine here have this and i
said i love this college and and then we
moved on but um there's soap but but the
woman the woman Hank that's how I i I
just I went to the comedy show and the
manager came up to me after I would not
shut up because it's the worst right yes
women it even as a woman comic and
there's women in the audience yelling
for some reason the Alliance is still on
her stir on their side unless unless
they are good being a complete and utter
tool to it like where it's like you
can't and people don't understand it's
like you should rip her apart you can't
you can't until it's bad yes until
because if it's got a really be bad or
else you just look like a bully yeah
yeah cuz you have a microphone and you
are not there just a little gal we're
just a little gal after all you're just
trying to have a good time why you gotta
be so well cuz I'm working yeah I don't
know uh yeah and then um with the the
crazy um so the guy who manager actually
came up to me and told me to shut it and
he actually in that when he told me to
shut up he actually said open mic is on
Sunday ah and literally and he was being
a dick yes but two weeks later I came
back no sunday yeah isn't that funny
that's how it happened and that's funny
cuz I actually say that to audience
members like when they try to be fine i
go yeah open mics on sundays right that
was that one of those guys over like a
sunday night here come back and sign up
circus it sounds like you get a good
start right and then uh it was like
heroin so yeah so six seven months later
somebody mentioned Lenny Bruce and I was
like who's that right and I was
literally belittled and then I went off
and bought an album and it was lovely
and Lenny Bruce is very funny what did
thing is is is I think bill hicks didn't
even get back to whatever we were
talking about is that Hicks has been
hacked so bad yes that when you try to
go back and listen to Hicks having never
heard Hicks it's hard to do it well you
know English I tell you this I bought I
bought dangerous on a cassette okay and
I remember telling Paul go Martin on a
golf course have you heard this guy bill
hicks and I only bought it because I was
on the road all the time and I just go
to buy anything to kill so other than
listening yeah dr. Laura and rush yeah
Limbaugh across the country where as you
drove right and because there wasn't
satellite radio yeah so we got you know
you and luckily you drive in the
afternoon it's weirdest sounds as
luckily because I was not i'm not a fan
and will never be a fan of brush
Limbaugh but he would be on and if you
drove across the country every station
had him on yeah you never lost that he
never yeah you as you got this entire
show and uh killed four hours right but
I bought bill hicks and I remember
thinking this guy is phenomenal this is
a genius and then uh you're right it
then then it became a little hackneyed
not his fault not his fault at all but
yes he was breaking ground yes but he
was the first guy who said who talked
about porn right and when people would
get on this case you'd be like I am NOT
alone right you know I am and then
everybody started and now Wow everybody
yeah if you don't talk about porn
something's wrong right and so but it's
so funny because my my romance novel
bent is a little bit of an homage to
that hmm because when i mentioned that i
read an occasional romance novel the
audience shuts the [ __ ] down and i say
out loud which is possibly stealing his
joke but also i don't think so is that I
am NOT alone in reading romance yeah I
am NOT sustaining a billion-dollar
industry by myself and I had never heard
that joke until recently and I was like
oh [ __ ] did I accidentally steal that
jokah knows like moon I don't think you
did I don't think I did and I don't care
it all right I'll thinking that's all
that's out now true or false yes before
we go back to Chicago yes my first time
ever to come to club i heckled as well
oh really no true or false oh that's
right it's a it's an actual I gotta say
false no it's true did you as well yeah
oh you can't tell you how psyched i am
be here yes the comedian was a guy named
Ricky Connor I always no longer with us
and he was doing a bit uh I don't
remember the bit but it was about
breasts okay and he was doing against
huh boom I'm you're always what's it was
you say for or against I think it was
for them okay all right he was doing he
was up there doing the thing
african-american gentleman yep and then
it was getting laughs and then then he
just kept going and going and going and
then eventually it's silent and he goes
I said and then it was like and the
always was almost kind of turning
against him because it was going on
without a laugh right and then he said
oh did I go too far on this brush joke
and I go yeah I think you're milking the
tip joke Oh placement freaking nuts
right cuz you essentially tag the I
tactus joke for him yeah I tagged his
joke yeah and you know my friends like
you man that's why you gotta do this man
that's right he's gonna be great cuz i
had gone to this club to watch it was
either the first man i did an open mic
which was after the show or was the week
prior right where's like I went to
investigated right cuz i remember i was
sat in a booth with my friends uh but it
was like this is why Jimmy this why you
gotta do this man's where you could do
it and then of course now 26 years later
yeah hey prick shut your mouth right you
don't mean right though when I have
we've all been in that situation though
when somebody says something in the
audience at tags that that is hilarious
yeah well you can do is go to Shea well
you have the right points now early out
of my career though in fact it was Larry
Wilmore that gave me this advice okay uh
because I was a good comic I like Larry
Wilmore great deal he's a great
television producer and great great
great ideas and I'm gonna take a stand
folks Larry Wilmore good guy he's doing
okay I like Larry I was working in a nap
Indianapolis with him and it was that
where it's like you know everything I've
now found exactly how to deal with an
audience and we're that's I've made him
literally curse yeah um but at the time
it's like I would almost go fishing for
hecklers okay so that I can make them
look stupid oh there's kind of what I
was doing yeah I didn't know I was doing
that right you but I was doing that
right and then sure enough same deal one
time a guy blah blah blah I might have
even been struggling right and blah blah
blah oh you're stupid sir he says
something back it got a
laughs there was go [ __ ] yourself and I
went nuts and then afterwards Larry goes
you know they're not always stupid
they're not always wrong and it was like
I don't even do a comedy this was maybe
91 so maybe what is that a year and a
half two years at the most right and it
was like wow that may be the best piece
of advice even to this day that I was
ever given yes it's like I mean
obviously I would have found it out and
figure it out myself right but like just
nice to have been to just laugh just
last give it to just give it to him
because then you you look like you're
having fun you're in on it yes and you
don't have to hey for less of it or
don't have to win everything right you
could be part of it you're there
together yeah it's it's a group it's a
group and I yet but all right comedians
great on though you're afraid like well
that guy gets a laugh I'm not gonna get
rebooked right oh that girl's got a
bigger life larger though the owners saw
that yeah all right [ __ ] that goes
through our heads great the committee
meeting that's being held haha isolate
that phrase yeah that's uh I had the
committee meeting you knew Robert Bobby
Bobby lamb Bob get lamb yeah I'll be
land it's a what I what I'm the only
thing I'm willing to do recently I've
decided is that that makes the committee
meeting even acceptable is that I only
read abridged minutes nobody needs to
hear the whole minutes it's a that's as
long as I keep it a bridge keep it tight
um no I'm not gonna lose friends I have
to go back to Chicago for a minute yep
do please do cuz of this we got we got I
forgot about Lou pardini you didn't loop
rd knee replaced bill champlin about six
years ago what does he play new pic
keyboards and sings and he's a great
vocalist grace in the last couple of
years yeah okay and he is phenomenal and
I will tell you this yeah her man 60s no
probably 50 s okay all right yeah uh
maybe low 60s but uh I have seen Chicago
since 1981 how many times uh more than
75 holy crap all right hunter time i
used to say 100 I don't think that's
accurate or even realistic right but
it's between 50 and 75 okay um if they
came to Chicago and they used to come
and do three nights at a venue yeah I
would go all three nights oh my god I
was that guy okay um like an 80 to see
different sets nope oh just other one do
different sets no I would just go
because I'm the biggest Chicago fan in
the world okay and you're wearing a
shirt I wore a diaper honor in honor you
were in a bit nice baseball shirt I hope
you took a photograph for the website so
i worship ugly shirt well now I'm going
to UM but no I didn't I the idea that a
Chicago concert could be going on in my
town and I'm not at it was not even
write like that was I was going right
okay you know like I went to see them
with my with my dad took me once and I
wasn't able to drive right uh and then
you know I saw my Chicago fest forever
where I'd see the matinee and the
nighttime show okay one time Gary Shara
and I uh our friends did not want to
stay for the late show okay and so they
were our ride and Gary never liked what
forgot her way home so we walked around
soldier field you know why they play
football yeah we walked around going is
anybody going oak forest does anybody go
to oak forest and a guy goes I'm going
but I don't have you can sit the back of
the pickup okay that's fine so we drove
you know which is against the law now
right right and probably was then I
doubt it but we sat in the back of this
I think as long as you guys were wearing
leashes that were real tight I don't
think we're wearing any shell out she
didn't jump out I probably have nine
Chicago shirts on because I had to buy
every souvenir as well did you do you
still have many she talked you know what
happened Jackie what happened here's a
here's sad tears how effing nuts Jimmy
Pardo is how it I my mom moved three
years ago okay from oak forest my
childhood well my high school we moved
there an 84 high school and my mom lived
there until three years ago okay when
she moved there was a box of all my old
chicago and all concert t-shirts oh that
I put on ebay and made a gazillion
dollars oh that's hilarious you know
what that is shrewd then
you bought them all back I'm all back
you didn't nobby what very different
well all the ones that i sold I then
went you know what I liked that shirt
and I want an ebay and I Bri bought
every one of those shirts like an a-hole
this is a beautiful story so story but I
think we can all learn from in the dark
forest this Savior souvenirs say savior
but the idea of like I saw what the
prices were going for yeah on ebay was
like well I couldn't and I did I made a
lot because I was selling t-shirts from
81 82 83 yeah that word on ebay the
chicago one so the all these Chicago
fans that were either new fans or new
collectors oh my god i can get this i
can get the chicago 16 tortured you know
$175 like I mean I was making bank and
then I eventually went back and bought
them all and when they and their
ill-fitting really can't wear them I
just have them now it's like right you
got to create a diorama of the people
yes admire it's what you got to do
shadow boxes shadow box shadow boxes
yeah meta p.m. which was a big hit by
handy good oh my god that up no dancing
it's a the first album on the first
concert I ever went to REO speedwagon i
went here through the year and i'll tell
you who open uh okay maybe 81 uh no i
can't tell you who open at the world
series of rock uh in a Milwaukee
Wisconsin at County Stadium oh so there
was like five bands on that show oh yeah
April joan jett april wine or wine
triumph nope um it was at april one
ruins give another and one other band
there was over three bands and then REO
curse they were when they were the peak
of their powers yeah they were uh and i
went just because a friend of mine was
like we're gonna go see this band and I
was like I don't know what that band is
and then I knew every song of course and
then um yeah that was a that was a crazy
and it was we each had a beer and a half
I think I was 14 and then I saw heart
thats a mere ah was it a big concert
year for me yeah I don't like live music
it turns out Oh such roots loud I love
it I like it in album for in my vehicle
I will go to
i will i I'm still but I will go to any
concert if I'm available right and
that's not true i was just invited to
one and i'm not going and it was it was
hard to say no i relay that i love i
love live music concerts i love them
okay and I think out on the bottom I
think it's michelle's you okay I think
it's the feeling I used to get as a kid
waiting in line like sleeping out
overnight to buy journey tickets okay
we're sleeping out overnight to buy
triumph as I mean you got to do you got
to you got to sleep out overnight oh
yeah out in front of sears at orleans
square oh that's awesome and we would
sleep outside and you know and and it
was a neat party like I didn't do drugs
or anything yeah or drink even right but
everybody else was right but somebody
would put a boom box if its journey we
listen to journey for nine hours oh my
god don't mean from midnight to 9am we
listen to journey oh that's and then we
know why our ticket it was a great so I
remember all of that so going to
concerts to me is basically that bring
it all the community and that's what
that is that's awesome that's community
Jimmy Pardo this has been a treat this
is when we are done we have four minutes
if you want well if we won't we have
three minutes okay I got I got 3x all
right I guess all right what how would
you like summation well first of all we
got it we got to tell people apart
casteth on live streaming it never not
funny calm right never not funny your
weekly podcast on Earwolf yes with mr.
Matt Belknap yes oh and on perk estevan
is me Matt Belknap iPad Francis yep and
the three of us are there for all 12
hours all 12 mirror there for 12 hours
we have a different guest every half
hour every fri i can tell you confirmed
at this time are weird al yankovic nice
uh jason Thompson from General Hospital
okay uh you Scott Aukerman paul f
tompkins okay i'm forgetting one other
Oh Sarah Silverman okay and there's
others but those are the only ones I can
remember at the time rich sommer from
edmond ok oh he's great he's been on the
dork for aetna games yeah that is a
board game man yes he is man way I'm
gonna say on the record away from my
show mm-hmm uh there are about five
people in this world that they're my
favorite people yeah and I mean that's
like and and rich summer is one of them
well he's a dave holmes is another okay
have you had dave holmes on I haven't I
haven't
no reason not to you should have him on
to talk about 80 s music and 90s music
okay he is great okay well then I will
dave holmes he is great Davis you're
listening uh Jackie at Jackie Kashian
com email me I could tell i should tell
you this he does not care for you so
it's probably not listening I probably
you know what I made a mistake even
bringing it up uh but yeah November 20th
park a stove on we are raising money for
Smile Train last year we raised a
hundred forty four thousand dollars our
goal is to beat that we are close to
raising Oh 44,000 that sounds gross
anyway boom ladies and well that's a
nice piece of business Jackie Kishan and
then Jimmy Pardo cow if people want to
see you to stand up comedy out of your
Joe Cole what if they want to do that is
it you got to her stuff on Jimmy from
yeah I do but I don't really have a lot
coming up I've got uh flappers and
burbank in the beginning of december
excellent i'm their thanksgiving weekend
myself i'm there are tickets that week
after that right after that excellent ah
and then I don't have anything till the
end of January uh the name of the place
is wise guys in Salt Lake City oh there
you go I think I'm their march which is
one of my favorite clubs trolley square
trolley square the other one no the
other one which I prefer I like
traveling square so look at us liking
all of salt lake city I don't I don't
like Charlie's Claire or I don't like
the people that go to that particular
show they're very nice to me they're
very lovely I don't like the notches
what's centered interesting life choices
here's the good news yeah people get to
go wherever they want to go man that is
the good news brother let me say this
yeah again a if you just want to dip
your feet in the water with Chicago yep
they have a new 40th anniversary best of
that kind of encapsulates all 40 years
obviously hilaire and it's got this it's
got the Warner brother years which are
the 80 year at the 80s and 90s word
everybody kind of shrug them off yeah
and then it's got the stuff from the 70s
so you get the best of both worlds oh
come that's a great place to start but
if you want to be the guy that says no I
want to immediately jump into albums
yeah CTA I mean they literally started
with the best ok and then chicago phi 2
is great chicago 5 is great
I think Chicago's 16 and 17 or grades 5
16 and 17 and then hot streets and 13
and 14 / hang on those are the bastard
child yeah those are the ones like it
was like oh those are the worst albums
ever made uh there's great stuff on
there as well what about nine nines our
greatest hits okay I like your like you
just wanna you might also want to look
into 21 and 20 n 1803 I don't know if
you bored have you tried sixth uh-huh
very good anyway oh they're not they're
not either and their [ __ ] on every album
oh sure but here's the thing about an
elbow I say for good songs that's a hell
of an album you're gonna do better than
that here you're gonna do better than
that with most of these all right some
you want some you want ladies Rangers
yeah we have we have listened to a good
solid 40 minutes about Chicago and I
think that we've been I didn't even get
into I didn't even dork out as much as I
could have we've grown I think we've
grown as people as America well
foreigners uh let me just tell you how
foreigners well some not the band
foreigner I'm just saying that we wait
we have some we have some overseas with
listeners they've also grown as
Americans and but what I have this to
say thank you so much for listening
Rangers you know the rules take care of
each other I had my hat my hat they're
dancing around my hat I hat my hat my
hat well what do you think of that if it
looks like a Mexican Hat dance and it
sounds like a Mexican Hat dance it's
most likely a Mexican Hackett so take
off your head and let stand yay oh my
god we why don't we just call that as
the end of the show